I got to tell you something really
really terrible happened to me last
night I I'm still recovering from it
some leftists on Twitter decided that
they wanted to hurt my feelings and
damaged my self-esteem by starting this
hashtag who is Matt Walsh hashtag who is
Matt Walsh and I was so devastated by
this hashtag I guess the point the
hashtag is they don't know who I know
what he knows who I am so it's you know
it's insulting it's like how you know it
makes me feel obscure or something I
guess that was a point so but I was so
devastated by the prospect of having my
name trend nationwide on Twitter that I
myself kept tweeting and pleading with
people please do not tweet hashtag who
is Matt Walsh the last thing I want you
to do is tweet hashtag who is Matt Walsh
I'm begging begging you please don't
tweet hashtag who is Matt Walsh and I
kept saying this over and over again and
in pleading with everyone to stop but um
but it didn't work and so in the end
they they got their way and my name was
trending he shouldn't whine on Twitter
but it was a way was as I said was
devastating I mean I was outraged I was
offended it was it's it's a worst attack
I felt first suffered but seriously that
really did happen some liberals tried to
hurt my feelings by making my name Trent
on social media it was the weirdest form
of attack I think I've ever suffered I
kind of liked it though I don't know if
that makes me a masochist but I kind of
liked the attack now next I'm wondering
if maybe they'll attack me by washing my
car or making me some cookies or
something I mean you know who knows
what's in store for me next all right
Michael Cohen wrapped up his public
testimony before a House committee
yesterday and the big bombshells
according to the media and now I'm gonna
read now directly from a USA Today
article which lists the what they call
the biggest bombshells and they are
according to USA Today that Trump knew
in advance that WikiLeaks plan to
release stolen emails damaging to
Hillary Clinton and that Trump confident
confidant Roger stone confirmed it with
WikiLeaks founder
as we discussed yesterday this isn't
it's not a crime that's not anything
it's just Trump heard a rumor that these
emails were gonna come out and he said
okay well that's good so there's nothing
there that's not a crime
it's not even he didn't even do anything
ethically wrong or morally wrong if
you're running against someone and you
find out there's going to be
embarrassing information about them
it's it so it's okay to be happy about
that and it's okay to you know not run
to the phone to get on the horn with
their camp and let them know hey guys
listen that would be a very
sportsmanlike thing to do I guess but
the best sportsman doesn't doesn't win
elected office in America anymore so
that's not much of a bombshell the other
bombshell the president personally
reimbursed Cohen for an alleged for an
illegal hush money payment to a porn
star
well we already knew about these claims
so to call that a bombshell is is not
much of anything and it's also not at
all a slam dunk as to whether it would
constitute a campaign finance violation
so not much of a bombshell there Trump
indirectly encouraged him to lie to kind
of encourage Cohen to lie to Congress
about his pursuit of a Trump Tower
development in Moscow well indirectly
means that he never actually said I want
you to lie Cohen
thought that he was picking up hints
that Trump was dropping with facial
expressions and that sort of thing but
III will say that I don't think anyone
has ever been brought up on obstruction
of justice or perjury charges because of
facial expressions so I think Trump is
is fine there and then the other
bombshell Cohen brought documents that
appeared to back up some of his claims
including a thirty five thousand dollar
check signed by Trump that Cohen called
a hush money reimbursement which doesn't
prove anything of course the fact that
he has a that he who was Trump's lawyer
has a check from Trump that doesn't
prove anything
rich men will often write big checks to
their lawyers and the fact that the
check exists does not prove at all what
the check was meant for now there were
other claims that were made Trump is a
racist Trump's a liar he's a fraud he's
a bad guy
he's you know divisive and all these
things you can decide whether you think
those claims are true or not but those
are not new claims first of all and they
don't have anything to do with criminal
conduct and there's no reason why we
need a house committee to investigate
them so I think the real bombshells can
be found in the things that Cohen denied
so he denied for instance that Trump
ever explicitly told him to lie he
denied that he had any evidence at all
that Trump was colluding with Russia
well that's pretty big one
he denied claims about there being
remember the the P tape story is that
well Cohen denied that there's
apparently some other rumor going around
about an another tape of Trump doing
something bad in an elevator or
something
Cohen denied that he shot down a lot of
these rumors and he said that he never
went to Prague to meet with Russian
officials which is which was a claim
that was made in that famous dossier so
that really is the those of the
bombshell it's what Cohen shot down he
undermined the the Russian collusion
case he undermined the obstruction of
justice case he undermine all these
things and this was supposed to be the
Democrats like star witness now just
reflect on this for a moment the
Democrats have their worst enemies
lawyer in their pocket they have the guy
who's been putting out fires for Trump
for the last ten years the guy who they
say knows where all the bodies are
buried
whatever dirt there might be whatever
skeletons lay hidden in whatever closets
this is the guy who would know about it
and this hearing which exonerated Trump
more than it implicated him is the best
they could do with that secret weapon
that is quite incredible when you think
about it
and I think it's incredibly favorable to
Trump really now it's true that you're
not gonna it's hard to argue that
politically or from a PR perspective
that Trump comes out looking better
because of something like this because
some of the claims that were made about
them are you know they're not illegal
they are embarrassing they don't make
him look good and I found it something
to be quite believable like Cohen told a
story about Trump there was some auction
where a portrait of Trump was being
auctioned off and Trump wanted to make
sure that he's his portrait was the
highest priced item so he arranged to
bid through anonymously to bid on his
own portrait so that it would be the
highest price now I personally find that
totally believable I absolutely think
that Donald Trump would do something
like that but it's not illegal and it
doesn't really matter and yeah it's
embarrassing but I don't think it's
gonna sway anyone one way or another
because we already know that about Trump
we know that he would do something like
that
but the Democrats will continue we we
have crossed some kind of Rubicon now
and we're in a place where the
opposition party is just gonna keep
investigating until they find a way to
get rid of this guy that they don't like
to get rid of this president and this is
a very dangerous place to be um keep in
mind that the left has had this attitude
about Trump from the very beginning
before there was any not because they
suspected him of any crimes or anything
but just from the very beginning they
despised everything about him and they
just cannot accept
they cannot emotionally accept that he's
president and still to this day that -
two years later more than two years
later they still can't accept it
and I could tell you when we reach the
point where the opposition party will
not accept the results of an election
you are teetering very close to the edge
of democratic collapse and that's where
we are that's what this is all about is
all the hearings and everything they
cannot accept it they just can't they
can't allow this guy to actually serve
out at least for years they can't allow
it to happen and it's it's gotten that's
why they're just throwing everything
they can against the wall because it's
really got nothing to do it
okay so we'll try rush inclusion there's
no rush inclusion we'll look for
something else they don't really care
about any of this stuff the all the
hand-wringing about oh no our election
was interfered with by Russia and Trump
is a secret Russian agent they don't
actually think that or Carib
it's just that was well that's one
Avenue we can explore to get rid of him
that doesn't work let's go over here
where was the Trump Tower thing well
okay that's not really working out let's
go over here
maybe we'll get a maybe there's an
obstruction of justice okay well no not
really so no they're just looking for
anything they can to to rid themselves
of of this man and no matter how you
feel about Trump that is it's got
nothing to do with Trump specifically
it's just it's a dangerous place to be
and you can't there's the what about it
what about is some thing that liberals
are doing now what they're saying yeah
but that's what Republicans did with
with Obama what about the Benghazi
hearings that went on forever yeah well
yeah you know what but that's a little
bit different because in Benghazi
Americans die people died in Benghazi
people were left to die
so something really bad happened and not
only that but we know that the Obama
administration lied about it after the
fact they're on tape they went out in
front of the American people lied about
it said it was because of a YouTube
video or whatever so when you've got
something that happened while this
person was in office people died because
of it well then obviously you need to
investigate that but the stuff that
Democrats are searching for does not
rise to that level all right now the
other big political news story today or
at least geopolitical in this case is
Trump and Kim jong-un in North Korea and
now that I've just defended Trump I'm
going to pivot to criticism the the
summit is coming to an end he was in he
was in Vietnam with Kim jong-un and they
were supposed to be working out a deal
and working out a deal for North Korea
too deep to denuclearize but it's coming
to an end and then no deal has been
reached Kim jong-un is not agreeing to
anything now this I wouldn't blame Trump
for that specifically but this comes
after Trump did his whole normal routine
now of heaping lavish praise on Kim
jong-eun a man who runs literal
concentration camps okay this is to
compare him to Hitler in this case
now let's compare wound Hitler is not is
not an exaggeration he actually has
concentration camps where he sends
innocent people to die and Trump praised
him as as he has been doing over the
last year or so he praised them I
thought in a an especially bizarre way
he praised Kim Jong anniver and he said
this kind of thing before where he
praised him for turning out so well even
though he comes from a rich family and a
lot of kids grow up in rich families and
they end up screwed up but not Kim Jong
hoon now Kim jong-un killed his family
members to retain power by the way so I
don't know if that compliment really
applies and right before Trump walked
away from the meeting he Trump covered
for hoon and said that hoon didn't know
anything about the imprisonment and
torture of otto warmbier remember this
was the American who was taken by the
North Koreans and tortured to death he
was finally let go when he was on
death's door and Trump cover for him and
said well you didn't know about that he
says he didn't do it now what do we get
from all this nothing but nothing but
international embarrassment and shame
really nothing else come came of it and
and this has been Trump's tact towards
North Korea for a while now and nothing
is coming but other than we're just
embarrassing ourselves now Trump's
reflexive defenders will say that this
is a brilliant diplomacy strategy and he
knows what he's doing
but then again see the problem is
Trump's reflective reflexive defenders
said it was brilliant diplomacy when
Trump was on Twitter trolling Kim
jong-un at the beginning of his
presidency calling him little rocket man
and stuff so he's trolled he's trolling
the guy on Twitter
that's brilliant and then he switches
strategies drastically and then goes
over there and kisses his feet and we
say well that's brilliant too they call
it brilliant literally no matter what he
does if he if he's if he's sucking up to
him it's brilliant if he's mocking him
it's brilliant if he stands on his head
and yodels the theme song to happy days
that's brilliant too well that actually
would be brutal
to be honest but so no matter what he
does it's brilliant and and I mean and
they know that right I'm not I'm not
breaking any new ground here we know
that that's that there's a certain
segment of conservatives who will just
doesn't matter what literally it does
not matter what he does they're going to
say it was it was the most artists thing
ever meanwhile of course again it this
doesn't need to be said either but it
goes without saying that if Obama had
publicly covered for a dictator who
tortured an American citizen to death
every conservative in the country would
explode with outrage and would not stop
exploding for probably about 15 years
over it and rightly so so it's all a
game it doesn't mean anything
the people who defend this performance
from Trump they very well know that
they'd they're only doing it because it
is Trump and if Trump radically changes
course they'll defend that too and and
just back and forth I just it is PI say
this to everyone I'll say two I would
say about Trump and his approach to Kim
jong-un maybe there's a middle ground
right between between trolling moon on
Twitter and mocking him and kissing his
feet like maybe there's in-between
somewhere you could you could settle and
then in regards to Trump for everyone
else it does seem like there are a lot
of people who will criticize him no
matter what he does and a lot of people
who would defend and no matter what he
does is it so difficult to just look at
each thing on a case-by-case basis and
actually assess whether or not you think
it was the right thing it's just it's
very unlikely that a human being will
always do something that you really
disagree with or that they'll always do
is do something that you agree with
that's just it's it's not just unlikely
it's impossible no human being is like
that no human being is going to line up
with you like that if you have your own
brain in your head and your own opinions
in your own perspective it's just you're
not going to find anyone on earth who
always does something you agree with or
always does something you disagree with
so if you find it when it comes to Trump
that you're always against him all the
time always well that probably is a hint
that you're not applying your brain
you're not
thinking you're just being reflexive but
on the other end of it if you find that
you're always defending him and that
over the last two years of him being in
office in the last I don't know four
years of him being on the political
scene you have never met in occasion
where you think he he deserves criticism
then again that's probably an indication
that you're not thinking you're not
using your head you're just
you've just attached yourself to him
like a barnacle and you'll go wherever
he goes and that that's not right either
that's not it's not even human that's
just that's not as human beings we're
not meant to we're not meant to just
surrender our critical capacities for
the sake of always defending some other
dude he's just a guy's a guy writing his
president but he's not Jesus Christ he's
not he's just he's just a guy and it's
okay criticize him sometimes and I think
pretty clearly look when you've got an
American president who is covering for a
dictator who we all know tortured an
American to death and we all know that
obviously the idea that Kim jong-un
didn't know he didn't know Kim Jong Lee
the dictator of the country didn't know
that there was a an American citizen in
a in a concentration camp so he didn't
know that come on come on we all know
that's not true so this to me seems like
something that pretty obviously was not
the right approach so we should all be
able to criticize that the Maneri of
conservative liberal doesn't matter
where you stand you could love most of
what Trump does but i but i but i think
that's one thing that we all should be
able to criticize and if you find you
can't even criticize that well i think
that's an indication you're just not
thinking critically all right let's move
on so Amy Klobuchar Klobuchar never
could figure
to pronounce your last name she's the
senator from Minnesota she's running for
president she's been in the news
recently because former staff members of
hers have come out many of them not just
one or two but many of them have come
out and have said that she's an abusive
unhinged tyrant to her staff and
according to these reports she berate
stems she throws things at them she cuts
them down insults them screams at them
so on and so on
I won't get into reading the specific
details if you've ever had a boss like
this then you can kind of imagine what
what we're talking about here now I
think there are many reasons not to vote
for this woman she's a Democrat first of
all is is one reason but if she were
conservative I still wouldn't support
her because of these stories and I'll
tell you why because I have noticed in
my life that you can really tell
everything you need to know about a
person's character and what they're all
about based on how they treat their
subordinates that's that will tell you
everything you need to know about a
person because if if you treat people
who have more power than you well well
then that's just self-interest you're
just you're just protecting yourself and
if you're generally fair to those who
are on your same sort of level then that
also is kind of self-interest that's
just networking that's being diplomatic
the only people that you really can
potentially get away with abusing are
those under you so we have to see you
know we have to see how you treat those
people to know what you're really all
about and if it happens that as soon as
you have someone under you you become
this abuse of timers and that just that
just tells us that you always were that
way you just never had an outlet for it
and now that you have an outlet well you
can let this part of you shine and it
just shows that you're not a very good
person Klobuchar is tried to explain
away these reports by saying well I'm a
taskmaster master I demand a lot I
demand perfection I'm a hard worker I
want my team to be hard workers you know
trying to cloak it
in this sort of positive perfectionist
type hue but people who really demand
perfection leaders who are really
perfectionist they aren't going around
throwing temper tantrums because they
demand perfection of themselves as well
that's what we're missing here and to
act this way it means you're not being a
good leader or a good person and good
leaders have dignity they have restraint
they have patience that's good
leadership any five-year-old can lead by
screaming and crying constantly anyone
can do that that's not that's not
leadership
but the thing that really bothers me is
so there's there's that deflection from
her camp which is ridiculous but the
thing that really bothers me is this
deflection that I've seen from many of
her defenders claiming that well turning
it into a man/woman thing and claiming
that she's only getting this criticism
because she's a woman it's sexist you
see if a woman acts this way then she's
crazy and she's terrible but if a man
does this then then we just say he's a
go-getter he's a tough guy
etc that's that's the line that I'm
hearing from some of them Kluber chars
defenders I find this line to be
amazingly off-base and completely
disconnected from any reality that I've
experienced this idea and you hear this
from feminists a lot this idea that
women get more criticism for character
defects women get more criticism for a
being abusive in the workplace really
women get more criticism for that isn't
the opposite the case if a man is a jerk
nobody has any problem calling him a
jerk and the other thing is you can call
a man a jerk without anyone calling you
sexist nobody no one is ever gonna call
you sexist for criticizing a man calling
him a jerk or calling him something
worse there are other there are worse
labels we might use other than jerk that
I can't use here and if you do that
probably people will agree with you and
no one's gonna call you sexist no one's
gonna make it a gender thing so only
a woman can potentially cloak her
jerkiness in this whole girl power
routine only a woman can dress up her
character flaws as some kind of feminist
statement only a woman can be
potentially celebrated for being a jerk
and only a woman can use the you're only
attacking me because I'm a woman excuse
so if anything it seems to go the other
way and it seems to me that when we talk
about abusive and inappropriate behavior
in the workplace generally speaking
we're almost always focusing on men
we're just giving we're letting women
off the hook entirely when we have this
conversation usually usually even though
anyone who's been in a working
environment in an office environment or
whatever anyone that's knows that there
are plenty of women who are also
inappropriate who engage in harassment
who are abusive we all know that yet
these conversations in this particular
case yes we happen to be talking about a
woman but usually we're talking about
men so it seems to me that women are
more likely to get off the hook with
these kinds of things because they at
least have the potential of turning it
into a feminist into an expression of
their feminism which is a potential that
obviously a man a man simply doesn't
have in and by the way if you another
example of this not exactly the same
thing but talk to a guy who's been
through Family Court some time to see
how this works
to see how behavior that is condemned in
men can often times especially in a
family court situation be excused in
women
so there are there
any of situations where a man is held -
or men are held to a higher standard and
and and where women wear excuses are
made for women that would never be made
for a man that's that's just simple fact
of the matter all right before we get to
emails I wanted to quickly mention this
Elizabeth Warren has rolled out a plan
for universal child care reading now
from Vox for some reason senator
Elizabeth Warren has rolled out a
sweeping plan to provide all Americans
with affordable childcare paid for with
a new tax on multi millionaires this is
the key part Warren envisions a network
of childcare facilities subsidized and
regulated by the government for all
children too young to attend school
facilities would charge families based
on their ability to pay now there are
many ways of at of criticizing this idea
the fact that it would be prohibitively
expensive is I think what most people
will point to and that's true but the
other thing with this idea is you know
people we already
many Americans millions of Americans
they already send their kids away to
government institutions starting at the
age of like five or younger because now
you what you've got pre-k and I think
now you even have pre pre-k pre-k 2 and
pre-k 3 whatever they call it so at a
very young age a lot of a lot of
Americans are sending their kids away to
government institutions to essentially
be raised by the government and now with
this Universal government subsidized and
regulated childcare idea and Elizabeth
Warren is hardly the first person to
come up with this but with this idea
well now we're going to take kids away
even sooner so the objective seems to be
let's get kids out of their parents arms
as quickly as soon as possible and put
them into the system that's what this is
really about it's about getting kids
away from the family plot tearing
away from the family and plucking them
into the system as soon as possible
that's the whole idea here and that's
the thing that disturbs me the most
about it even if even if it wasn't
prohibitive prohibitively expensive even
putting that aside I mean can we get can
we give a family you know a few years to
exist can we can we give the children a
few years to be with their parents to be
in the home do we have to move them into
the government system right away well
yeah that's what the left wants to do
because the left has for a very long
time seeing the family as a threat and
it is actually the family is a threat to
their agenda because as parents we can
teach our kids what we want we can
instill in them the values that we want
to instill and the left has no control
over that
and they don't like not having control
all right
so go check out your emails Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com you can email with questions
comments concerns death wishes whatever
you got some interesting emails today
this is from Michael he says Matt just
wondering your opinion on women being
eligible for the draft personally as
someone who served two combat tours in
Iraq I think this is a huge mistake I
can't remember a worse day than when we
lost women during one of my tours was
horrible when we lost brothers but when
we lost a sister there are no words for
what for when that happened it would be
interesting to hear your opinion on the
matter hi Michael well first of all
thank you for your service I think your
opinion on the subject is much more
interesting and important than mine so
in a lot of ways I could just leave it
there you've already given your opinion
as someone who's been in the thick of it
for what it's worth I completely agree
with you and when I say I agree with you
it's more like what you're saying to me
now this is what I've heard from all
from I want to say every but that
probably isn't true so let's just say
almost every person every veteran every
combat veteran I have spoken to about
this and I've spoken to a lot of them
almost every single one has said the
exact same thing as you that they do not
think this is a good idea they don't
want women drafted they don't want women
on the frontlines of combat it is the
only reason I want to say every single
one I've talked to has had that opinion
but maybe there have been a few hear
that but vast majority of combat
veterans seem to agree with you and so
for one thing Who am I to disagree if
this is the the people that have been in
that position if this is their opinion
then I think we should defer to it so on
the other hand I understand you know I
can sort of under there are some
conservatives who say you know what yeah
let's draft women feminists they want to
be like men they they say they're just
like us in every respect well let's hold
them to it then so yeah go ahead and
send
out to the front lines all these
feminists say I can do anything a man
does okay yeah well go ahead send him
out and I get that instinct right fair
is fair but you know what my daughter
isn't a crazy feminist and I don't want
her to pay the price for the sake of you
know hoisting feminists on their own
petard giving feminists a dose of their
own medicine or whatever I don't want my
daughter get caught up in that's not
fair to my daughter that's not fair to
all the other women and girls who are
not feminists and don't go around
claiming this and even aside from that
more importantly the objective here you
know is not to make some sort of point
and we can't make the same mistake that
the left is making you know for
feminists and the left if they would
support something like this then they
support it to make a point to make sort
of an ideological point and we don't
want to make the same mistake on the
other end this is not about making a
point this is about what's best right
just what's the best thing morally
what's the best thing from a perspective
of military strategy and from those two
perspectives
obviously drafting women is not the best
thing so thank you thank you for your
email this is from Heidi
she says hi Matt I had an interesting
argument with a friend recently she was
arguing that sometimes it can be morally
acceptable for a person to steal if
someone is in a desperate situation it
can be morally okay for them to steal as
long as they are not physically hurting
someone else what do you think is
stealing objectively morally wrong or is
it only wrong depending on the situation
all right this is a is a fascinating
question and I've to me I've argued
about this with people before here's how
I deal with it I think I would say that
yes it is objectively wrong always wrong
to steal stealing by definition is wrong
just like murder by definition is wrong
however killing by definition
is not necessarily wrong all murder is
killing but not all killing is murder
there are situations where it's morally
okay even morally laudable to kill in
defense of someone else in defense of
yourself
so can the same distinction be made with
stealing as in are there times when
taking someone's stuff without
permission is not actually stealing and
I would say yes so in a sense I think
you and your friend are both right that
maybe it's and maybe I'm just inventing
this distinction right now but it's I
think it's a necessary distinction so
let's look at an extreme example I
recently watched a really depressing but
powerful movie called first they killed
my father and it's set during the Khmer
Rouge regime in Khmer Rouge regime in in
Cambodia back when the Communists were
wiping out you know two million people
and it follows one family focusing
especially on a young girl like I said
it's very depressing movie so I don't
even know if I can recommend it but
powerful so it focuses on this family
who like so many other Cambodians were
taken by the government thrown in prison
camps eventually her whole family was
killed and she was forced to be a child
soldier but in the labor camps the
prisoners were forced to among other
things they were forced to work the
fields and harvest crops and they were
being starved the whole time so you see
these scenes where people sometimes kids
are stealing vegetables and crops and
trying to sneak them into the pockets or
whatever so they can eat it or take it
home to their family and share it so
they don't starve to death and if they
were caught they'd be beaten or killed
for stealing now it's true that the
crops didn't belong to them
legally speaking but was it stealing
well no I would say of course it wasn't
they have every moral right to eat
stealing in that case was not stealing
another way of looking at it is they're
starving you have food you
no moral right not to share your food I
think is the way of looking at it your
moral obligation is to share your food
with someone who's starving
and if you don't they have a moral right
to take it
I mean provided you're not starving also
now this is a slippery slope of course
this this principle can be abused
certainly just like the principle that
killing is you know the prey there's a
principle that killing can be acceptable
something
well that's abused all the time there
have been millions of murders have
occurred throughout in the world
throughout history by people who claimed
that they were killing for the right
reason and they weren't so the principle
can be abused but that doesn't mean that
that doesn't negate the principle itself
so I think the point here is really
about ownership those kids in the prison
camp or within their moral rights to
take some grain or some corn or whatever
because at the end of the day the owner
of those crops is not really the owner
God owns everything right we're we're
just renting everything that we have and
so if someone legitimately has a greater
moral claim to something then they have
a divine claim to it and and they can
take it in that case there was a saint
who who said that were compared phrasing
but there was a saint who said words to
the effect of if you have two coats in
your closet the second coat doesn't
belong to you because there's someone on
the street freezing to death and the
coat belongs to it's that person's coat
not yours and you have to give it to
them now that's kind of an extreme way
of looking at it but there's some truth
to it isn't there is this an argument
for communism no of course not because
I'm not communism is the government owns
everything I'm not saying that that's
communism that's not me my argument is
God owns everything and God entrusts
what we own to us and so that means that
we do own it in a very real earthly kind
of sense but not in a totally absolute
sense
so if you're walking down the street and
there's a guy freezing to death and you
have an extra coat or something yeah you
do have a moral obligation to give it to
him
God didn't give you the ability to buy
multiple coats so that you could amass a
collection while other of his children
you know die of frostbite so I think
that's the again I mean you know it's
just there is this slippery slope and I
think the extreme examples we talked
about we're stealing isn't really
stealing morally speaking you're not
going to find very many of those
situations in the modern United States
but they do exist they can't happen so
interesting question all right let's see
how much time do we have
all right well we'll do this one I've I
keep wanting to get to it then I run out
of time so this is from Daliah
or Delia sorry I'm I'm not pronouncing
your name right says I'm a big fan of
the show been a fan of yours since your
days on your own blog before the blaze
back with the alpaca grooming tips good
times and I've been trying to get this
question in front of you since then I'm
a Christian woman clearly pro-life what
would your advice and thoughts be in
those extremely rare cases where the
pregnancy does in fact threaten the life
of the mother in terms of law
sure but more importantly from a moral
from a more personal level like if you
were advising a friend I'm not referring
to the situations you've touched on
already such as an expectant mother who
has cancer and treatments may harm or
kill the child but that is a tragic
choice situation I'm referring to cases
like an ectopic pregnancy where the egg
implants in the fallopian tube I tend to
think very far ahead and when I realized
that there is even a tiny chance that I
would find myself in that situation I
felt extremely torn up about it
and I would like your thoughts on it all
right
so ectopic pregnancy that's a
legitimately hard case let me give some
thoughts on for though
aren't familiar as she mentioned an
ectopic pregnancy is when a fertilized
egg does not implant in the uterus but
implants somewhere else and and usually
in the fallopian tube although it could
be you know there are other options
which is why an ectopic pregnancy is you
know often also called a tubal pregnancy
and in that situation obviously a
pregnancy cannot go to term in the
fallopian tube obviously The Tragically
the pregnancy is doomed at that point
for certain nothing there is not going
to be a birth it will end on its way on
its own one way or another and soon so
and that's an important point because
when people try to justify late term
abortion based on life of the mother
scenarios they can't use ectopic
pregnancy because you're not making it
to 28 weeks with an ectopic pregnancy
what will happen much earlier than that
is that the tube will burst if you don't
do something about it the tube will
burst and and it could very well kill
the mother if she doesn't get to the
hospital in time she could bleed out now
I've never spoken to anyone who thinks
that the mother has a moral obligation
to just wait for her tube to burst and
potentially bleed to death I've I've
maybe that opinion exists out there I've
never encountered it myself I think that
such as such a course of action would be
extremely imprudent and possibly
actually immoral because it's just so in
that case the woman would be so reckless
with her own life I mean it would almost
be suicide so then the question is what
do you do how do you deal with it well I
can tell you that the the classic kind
of answer that moral theologians and
philosophers and so on you know the
super-smart Christians who spend their
time thinking about these kinds of stuff
this kind of stuff what they've come up
with the answer hinges on the principle
of double effect and the principle of
double effect states the
it can be morally permissible to engage
in an otherwise legitimate act for the
sake of some morally legitimate outcome
even if that act will also have an
unintended and otherwise undesirable and
even tragic outcome now this is not
really important point here this is not
ends justify the means that's not what
this is
because ends justify the means is when
you commit an objectively evil act in
the hopes of a desirable outcome so ends
justify the means that's like spreading
rumors about some rival in the workplace
to try to get them fired so that you can
win the big promotion that's ends
justify the means that's just evil
that's wrong the promotion itself may be
good but what you did to achieve it was
evil double effect is not like that so
how does this apply to an ectopic
pregnancy situation well it's going to
seem to be like splitting hairs at this
point and it is but when you get to
these really complex moral dilemmas
that's what you're left with you're left
with this sort of moral hair-splitting
and there's no way around it so most
Christian philosophers agree that double
effect would apply if you were to remove
the fallopian tube where the where the
pregnancy has happened and thus you
would end the pregnancy obviously kill
the the life in the process but your
intent was to save the mother and the
act was removing the fallopian tube
which will inevitably kill the baby but
that is an unintended result it's a bad
result but unintended and you were not
directly bringing about that that death
now the thing is though a doctor
probably is not going if you're actually
in now you what you were saying is well
okay what if you're actually in this
situation well if you're actually in
this situation your doctor probably is
not going to recommend removing a
fallopian tube from a purely medical
perspective that would be an unnecessary
step and that would be a step that will
for one thing
severely hinder your ability to get
pregnant in the future that's kind of
like a major surgery which a doctor will
say it's totally unnecessary we don't
need to do that so what though what
they'll want to do what they'll suggest
is that we give you a drug which will
for lack of a better phrase it will
flush out the fallopian tube and end the
pregnancy and you know and and that will
be it but the drug is an abortion drug
and there's no way around it it's an
abortion drug that they'll want to give
you which is why from what I've read
most Christian thinkers have said that
it would be it would not be morally
permissible to take the drug because
then in that case you are directly
attacking that life and and you can't do
that so double effect doesn't apply I
actually disagree or I'm not sure that I
do agree I'll put it that way
I don't personally see why the principle
of double effect wouldn't be able to
kick in even if you were to take the
drug in that situation because it seems
to me that the intention is to save the
mother and the act is to take a drug
which clears out a blocked fallopian
tube the fact that a human life is part
of what is blocking the fallopian tube
is is you know and and it too will be
will be cleared out that is an
unintended consequence so it it seems to
me that that's morally it's not very
much different from just removing the
fallopian tube entirely again splitting
hairs but that's what we have to do I
just I don't seem really a distinction
between those two things because either
way you're obviously doing something
that will end that life and I think at
both cases you could argue that that
obviously is not the intention we know
that and the the ending of the life is
not is not what you you're not directly
doing that that's not your because it's
not your direct intention so I don't
there you go it's it's a difficult case
the point
that pro-lifers here's the really
important point pro-lifers do not have a
cavalier attitude about these kinds of
things we don't think that a woman has a
responsibility to die for the sake of a
doomed pregnancy but these kind of
situations where a pregnancy has to be
has to be ended in this way for the sake
of the mother they are extremely rare
they are almost always very early on in
pregnancy and as I've said it would
never be necessary in the later stages
of pregnancy in a late-term situation
because in that case if you got to get
the baby out there are plenty of
situations where that might happen but
then you just take the baby out and
there's a very good chance the baby will
survive there's no reason to kill the
baby out of them so it's only really
with this ectopic pregnancy situation
where you've got this kind of dilemma
and they're simply if you find yourself
in that kind of position
there is simply no easy answer and
there's absolutely nothing you can do
that's going to result in that baby
being born and surviving nothing so you
know those are the choices that you're
that you're left with but it's very
intricate question a very very
interesting question so thank you for
that email and I'll be interested to you
know get to field your emails after the
show to see what you all think about the
atopic pregnancy situation and I'll
leave it there I will by the way see you
at CPAC today if you're gonna be a seat
back all the I'll be wandering around
I'm not speaking or anything but I'll be
wandering around the hallways maybe
maybe just shouting I'll be shouting a
speech to random people as I walk maybe
so I'll see you there
Godspeed